[Music]
this is your tech news briefing for
thursday june 30th i'm julie chang for
the wall street journal filling in for
zoe thomas
celsius one of the largest crypto
lenders has been under watchful eyes
from investors in recent weeks in
mid-june it said it was freezing all
withdrawals swaps and transfers between
accounts for its more than one and a
half million users citing extreme market
conditions
and last week it hired restructuring
attorneys for a potential bankruptcy
filing
celsius had pitched itself as less risky
than a bank and even said it could offer
better returns but according to investor
documents from 2021 reviewed by the wall
street journal the lender had little
cushion in the event of a downturn or
mass withdrawals
as of last summer it had 19 billion
dollars in assets and about 1 billion
dollars in equity by comparison north
american banks and the s p 1500
composite index typically have a median
assets to equity ratio of less than half
that according to data from factset
here to tell us more about the latest
insights into celsius's business is our
reporter elliott brown hi elliott thanks
for coming on the show thanks for having
me
so elliot can you start us off by
telling us about how celsius its ceo or
the company pitched itself to the crypto
market celsius was
one of the sort of higher yield crypto
platforms out there so what that means
is they were basically saying anyone who
has crypto you can sort of store your
money with us like a bank and then we'll
give you really high interest rates and
the reason that we can give you these
high interest rates is because we're
passing along all the profits that we
get from business that we do and we're
giving them to you whereas a bank just
keeps your profits and and gives them to
fat cat executives so that was
essentially the pitch okay so that's how
celsius presented itself to potential
customers but you've been looking at
investor documents what did you find
yeah so we got a hold of essentially
what they were offering to investors in
the company itself which is different
from sort of depositors who gave crypto
to celsius and those basically paint a
picture that celsius was this really
high risk highly leveraged bank with
very little cushion uh in case something
went wrong and those are sort of the
recipes for all the reasons that banks
have regulations because if a bank is
going to be storing your money and
giving you interest
if you want to withdraw your money then
it's really important that the bank can
do that and of course what's happened
with celsius is you know in mid-june
they froze withdrawals uh because they
were unable to give people the money
that they wanted back so people gave
them money and then they couldn't get it
back and so that's the uh essential
problem that they have presumably
because uh some of these risks played a
role though we don't have the specifics
on that and what has celsius said about
all of this
celsius has been relatively mum they
basically said that you know in mid-june
they said that they were freezing
withdrawals because of extreme market
conditions and
otherwise they didn't comment to us for
the story and have stopped really
communicating and the journal has
reported that they've hired advisors to
advise on a potential bankruptcy filing
so we know things aren't going great
over there
you mentioned that celsius didn't have a
lot of money sloshing around but it had
a cushion as you've said it was holding
on to a lot of money from crypto
investors so
where did all of that go
so basically celsius did have a business
model akin to a bank which is when a
bank takes your money
and you deposit it that bank is usually
taking that money and it doesn't just
keep it in a vault ready to hand you
back bags of cash it goes and then gives
people small business loans or gives
people mortgages
so
what celsius was doing is whereas a bank
might have relatively stable loans that
it's doing to make money for most of its
its funding celsius was lending to a
whole bunch of other financial firms in
the crypto sector and so crypto is
considered just this incredibly high
risk product or area to lend and that's
where like some huge portion of
celsius's
you know deposits were going to
invest or lend to other things in in
crypto land and that also included they
made their own invested in their own
bitcoin mining operation and so if you
deposited money with them then they're
taking that money and essentially buying
like servers to mine bitcoin which is
kind of hard to then immediately give
you your money back if you want it back
the next day
do you have a sense for when things
started to go wrong for celsius was
there one moment that was just like the
turning point for it
with them we don't because it was a
pretty binary thing it was uh well from
what we've seen publicly it was pretty
binary it's there there wasn't enough
money they weren't able to fulfill
enough requests to take money out then
they said we're freezing withdrawals uh
now generally in crypto land what's been
happening is
in the past number of months the
declining value of all cryptocurrencies
has led to
you know so far it seems to be this kind
of slow one domino to the next uh maybe
that's not the best analogy but clearly
there's some connection when bitcoin
goes down by 60 70
then people who had investments in that
and those investments were sort of tied
to other investments there gets to be
this effect that you know spreads from
one to the other so does that affect
what's referred to as contagion in the
crypto sector yeah so i think the big
fear right now is much like we saw in
the 2008
financial crisis
when
lehman failed and and then we all
thought that you know merrill lynch
could fail and and you know one bank
failing was going to lead to another
because one bank lent to the other and
other people then you know their loans
went to zero and then nobody had enough
money kind of riding around and the
government had to step in
um i think that's a fear of what could
happen here alright that was our
reporter elliot brown elliot thanks
again for being here thanks for having
me
and that's it for today's tech news
briefing if you want more tech stories
check out our website wsj.com
and if you like our show please rate and
review it you can do that wherever you
get your podcasts i'm julie chang for
the wall street journal thanks for
listening
[Music]
you